at san jose state
university we discover who we want to be
for ourselves for our families for our
communities
different and unexpected begin here
at the heart of a transforming valley in
a city that is tough and beautiful
we are spartans
the u.s is setting new records with the
corona violence we don't afford to
debate this issue any longer
just not safe we need to hang on double
down do the kind of thing 19 infections
continue to rise across every minute of
my life right now
is devoted to trying to end this pancake
we have nearly doubled
today there is reason to hope dr anthony
founches says
the cavalry is coming
i want to thank you for being everything
that we want a doctor to be
especially in these difficult
circumstances
every doctor knows that sometimes the
best approach to treating a patient
involves telling them something that
they don't want to hear
this is always going to be a difficult
conversation but even more so
when you're dealing with an entire
country you're dealing with
a new and deadly illness and a
population
that's shocked and confused about the
best way to fight that knowledge i think
we're facing a whole
lot of trouble you've had to be the
bearer of bad news to more people than
possibly anyone in human history but you
stayed the course
you've given it to us straight
regardless of the potential backlash
so for everything you've done thank you
the kobit
19 pandemic has been a very hard
situation
for us as a society there's a lot of
misinformation
there's a lot of tension on what to do
but one constant has always been dr
anthony fauci my husband and i have two
children they're twins and they're
seniors in college
before we sent them off to school this
year we of course had a discussion with
them giving them advice
and the most important advice we gave
them this year comes from you dr kauchi
dr pouchy a new enid restaurant will eat
in the restaurant
when you fly in an airplane we'll fly in
an airplane
when you get the coveted vaccine we will
get the coveted vaccine
doctor fauci thank you thank you so much
for everything you do for the well-being
and the health of every single person
that lives in the united states
of north america muay thai ricardo dr
fauci muchisimas gracias
thank you so much congratulations on
receiving this year's prestigious first
award from the san jose state university
school of journalism and mass media
i can't think of a more deserving
professional to receive this year's
honor
you have literally guided our country as
you have for many many decades of
national service
with the national institutes of health
through an unprecedented crisis
and in particular you provided sound
counsel to companies such as ours
into businesses across the private
sector to help keep our people safe
and our operations running and for that
i will always be grateful
reporter at kpix5 we share the same
values of truth
driven by science and data thank you for
all you've done for keeping our nation
safe for decades and congratulations on
your award tonight
thank you and congratulations to dr
anthony fauci for being this year's
recipient of the hearst award
your years of knowledge and the way that
you use your wisdom and expertise to
help guide america through this pandemic
is the reason why i choose to trust your
voice
thank you for all that you've done and
all you continue to do for us
i would like to say it's dr fauci
how much every time i saw him he was an
inspiration
i started out thinking that he was
merely a tough little guy who was
hanging in there
and making his way but the more i saw
him
the more courageous he got the tougher
he got
the way he stood his ground so much that
i came to believe that he in fact was
the tallest man
in that entire administration i would
like to thank you
and congratulate you on your award
as a hearst winner thank you
you are getting an award that carries
the name of william randolph first you
know in journalism
uh honesty and integrity are the
cornerstones
of what we do and that's what you have
brought uh to this nation
uh throughout this pandemic honesty and
integrity when we go to the doctor's
office
you want the doctor to be honest with
you and tell you what your ailments are
what the prognosis is and what you need
to do to get better that's exactly again
what you have done for this nation you
are an american treasure you're an
american patriot
i can't stress enough how valuable your
contribution has been
your leadership your guidance sticking
with the facts
even when you don't know them thank you
so much for what you've done and what
you continue
to do for us all deep gratitude for
the great amount of hard work that you
have done to lead us through
this incredible pandemic you have served
as a keen role model for all of us
in the health professions thank you
thank you for being a prominent voice of
reason this year in the media
truth seeking is essential in journalism
myself as well as my classmates
are very grateful to have you as a
source of timely and accurate science
communication during the cove 19
pandemic
i admire your intelligence i admire your
leadership
and your logic but most of all i admire
your honesty throughout this entire
pandemic that we're all facing
my children ages 15 and 12 consider you
their american hero thank you so much
for keeping them
safe and healthy congratulations on this
award
good evening i'm dan rather and first of
all i want to thank the hearst
foundation and the
san jose state university school of
journalism
for the privilege of taking part in this
ceremony to honor the great dr fauci
dr fountain congratulations
your dedication your unrelenting hard
work
all during the covet 19 pandemic
your courage and your
absolute dedication to making sure that
the american people got the information
they needed
often amidst controversy and
unpleasantness will go down in the
history
of this period of our country you are
and rightfully so a legend in your own
time
on behalf of myself and my family
and i think i can say so on behalf of a
grateful nation
thank you dr thatcher congratulations
dr foucher congratulations
voices across america coming together
with gratitude live from the virtual
campus
of san jose state university in the
heart of silicon valley
welcome to this time-honored celebration
of the first amendment rights
of we the people and the free press
in the united states and we want to
thank all of you for joining us
for this very special occasion this is
the 2020
william randolph hearst foundation award
ceremony
by the school of journalism and mass
communications
i'm your host journalism professor bob
rucker former school director and former
cnn correspondent in san francisco where
i first met dr fauci
many moons ago along with our current
director dr phyllis west
and our colleagues as well as all of our
students
we are thrilled now to say those words
the man of the hour is here
congratulations
and welcome dr falchi
thank you professor rucker for that very
kind introduction
and warm greetings to you all it gives
me great pleasure
to join you virtually today at san jose
state
it is an extraordinary honor to be
chosen
by the faculty of the school of
journalism and mass communications
to receive this william randolph hearst
award
and i thank you so much for this
recognition
knowing that great communicators have
received this award
before me people i have long respected
such as dan rather and jim acosta
makes this day extra special to me
and to be honored by your great jmc
school and to now be a small part
of your long legacy of excellence is
very meaningful to me
as you know unlike dan and jim
and your previous awardees i am not a
journalist
or a communications specialist but a
physician
scientist and a public health official
these are two very different career
paths
that have some common features
first in my business as in yours
you are never quite done there is always
more to learn
and more questions to ask whether you
are assessing a patient
conducting a lab experiment meeting with
public health leaders
or reading up to prepare for a media
appearance
there are always more angles to cover
and more follow-up questions
in our respective professions we often
have a subliminal feeling
of unfinished business this feeling
however
is not necessarily a negative since it
can be transformed
into something productive and positive
by spurring us to further action
it is always humbling and anxiety
causing
to realize that you will never know as
much as you want to
or need to know after all these years
this remains true for me as a physician
and a scientist
and as a public health official since
the consequences of getting something
wrong
and not being aware of something that
you should have known
can be serious this of course is also
very true
in journalism the feeling
that there is more to learn reminds us
to dig in and read more
ask more and better questions and most
importantly
to listen to what people tell you
only by really leaning in
reading listening questioning
can you begin to get to the point where
you really understand the subject
and can effectively communicate what you
know
to an audience i've learned this over
many years as a government official
who has been called upon over six
presidential administrations
to communicate complex information
and concepts to a wide range of
audiences
this has been especially true with
emerging infectious diseases
during my career at the national
institutes of health
my colleagues and i have encountered
many infectious outbreaks and epidemics
going back to the very early days of
aids in 1981
through the anthrax attacks sars
pandemic flu ebola zika
and now cover 19.
the current pandemic of coba 19 poses
the biggest threat to global health
in more than 100 years the u.s pandemic
recently has reached perilous heights
with the numbers of cases and
hospitalizations
tragically eclipsing all earlier records
my experience with covert 19 has
reinforced some key lessons
about communications that i have learned
over many
outbreaks in the previous four decades
for me these apply to all
audiences whether i'm speaking to the
president or vice president
a senator or a congressman a reporter or
producer
scientific audiences or the general
public
or for that matter writing an article a
commentary or even a research paper
first among these is fidelity to the
truth
in the realm of science and public
health most all truths are revealed by
science based evidence
and data people need to hear the truth
as it is rather than as they might want
it to be
over time truth-telling bid builds
credibility
so we must always tell the truth even if
it means
i just do not know consistency and truth
telling is critical
because consistency maintains integrity
second transparency is key
from past disease outbreaks we know that
we earn public trust
when we are open and honest and do not
withhold information
we must make sure that everyone
understands
where we are going what our goals are
and how we propose to achieve them
we must keep our eyes on our objectives
provide regular public updates and lead
by example
when we falter in transparency some
people
understandably either stop believing
what we say or just stop
listening all together third
in the realms of public health and
journalism and related fields
well for that matter most any other
profession
we must communicate clearly
to achieve understanding now i am the
product of eight years of jesuit
education and throughout my career
the jesuit tenet of precision precision
of thought
and economy of expression has informed
how i think
how i write how i communicate with the
public
we must use language that everyone can
understand
and it is crucial today that we extend
our skills and efforts
to a broad spectrum of audiences via a
variety of outlets
be a traditional media and social media
among others
to which people get their information
now putting all these principles into
practice
is essential to building public trust
and science
as the pathway to resolving
the covet 19 pandemic and ensuring
that the fruits of our research such as
vaccines
have the greatest potential benefit
in this regard we can be heartened by
the rapid pace of scientific progress
including
extremely encouraging data showing a
high degree of efficacy
for candidate covert 19 vaccines in
large-scale
clinical trials never
has a vaccine been developed in so short
of time
of course a vaccine may will not be
and certainly is not a magic solution
by itself for some time
we still will need to adhere to simple
public health measures
such as universal masking physical
distancing
and avoiding crowds that we know these
things work
to stem virus spread getting the
messages out about the value
of proven low tech covert 19 prevention
tools
in clear credible and coherent ways
will continue to be a communications
challenge
once covert 19 vaccines are approved to
deploy
which could be actually as early as the
end of this year
there will be powerful tools for us now
to help us protect the vulnerable and
gradually help quell and eventually
end the coven 19 pandemic for everyone
and thus heal and restore
our upended lives once again
we have formidable communication
challenges ahead of us
as we work to convey with honesty
transparency and clarity
the benefits of vaccination to sometimes
very skeptical audiences i imagine
some of the jmc school students watching
today
will contribute important articles radio
and tv segments
and other communications products to
these
important issues some of you have
already have i'm sure
so let me say again how grateful
i am to be so honored
by san jose state with the william
randolph
hearst award please stay
safe keep well
and continue your important
and outstanding work
thank you very much doctor we appreciate
that very much
if i may i would like to tell everyone
in just a moment we're going to give you
a proper welcome
from our university president but before
i do that i just want to ask you one
follow-up
question as you know the governor has
already said that he's going to have to
put the brakes on reopening the state
and we're looking at the concept of
curfews
is that something that you endorse is
that something that you think should be
done now
you know what i have learned uh
professor
is that there are differences depending
upon where you are
and what the state of the outbreak is in
your particular region your state
your city or what have you it is
certainly true
that in other countries curfews
for example for people in general
curfews
for bars closing at certain times for
restaurants closing at certain times
has actually helped when you look at
what happens
as you get late into the evening people
let down their guard
people maybe drink a little bit too much
people get in congregate settings
you don't like to be very prescriptive
but sometimes when you're dealing
with the seriousness of the situation
right now
i leave it up to the good judgment of
the leaders of your states and your
cities
to make that but if they make that
decision i certainly think
the basis upon which it if it's sound i
would back that
very good we'll have more q a with our
distinguished guests in just a little
bit but right now it is time
to bring in the president of this
university so we'll ask right now
if dr mary laposia
let's say a few words well thank you
thank you bob
and uh dr fauci that was an incredibly
diplomatic though direct answer so
kudos to you there's a reason we're
honoring you here today
but let me just uh send you a big
spartan welcome
uh to you across the miles and to all
who have joined us
on youtube and on this zoom uh
presentation today
i'm so glad that you are all here to
help us present this special award and
celebrate
an extraordinary guest of honor bob i
want to congratulate you and the faculty
for selecting dr fauci for this award it
was a bold and
entirely appropriate selection and i
know
that we all very much appreciated
hearing from him just now
and learning more about his life's work
and experiences
in the media during the pandemic i know
many of us have watched him many times
over these last months it is truly a
coup for us to have someone of dr
fauci's stature here with us today
some around the country might be
surprised to learn that he's receiving
an award from a prominent
journalism school but this program also
has a global reputation for excellence
in public relations
and advertising in higher education so
it really does make sense when you stop
and think about the unique and important
role dr fauci has played these past
months
communicating such vital information to
the american public
the fact that he has done so in the face
of great stress
uncertainty and pressure demonstrates a
level of integrity and honesty
that many of our public and political
figures would be wise to emulate
and i know that our students have
learned much from
as we all look forward to next week's
thanksgiving holiday
i think i can speak for millions of
people around the country when i say we
are all thankful to have had you with us
throughout this global pandemic
helping us to understand this virus and
explaining how we can best deal with it
in a way that keeps us
and our most loved ones safe and i just
urge all who are listening
to heed dr fauci's advice
dr fauci we know your time today is
precious and so we're honored that
you're spending part of it with us
the most transformative university in
the nation
yes you heard right and you probably
noticed this in the video clip earlier
money magazine gave us that distinction
earlier this year
and i'm not shy about pointing it out it
is actually due to programs like our
school of journalism and mass
communications
that has helped us to earn this
distinction
the school was founded way back in 1936
and remains the largest of its kind in
northern california
we are proud of its distinction as one
of the top
nationally accredited programs in the
united states
graduates of the school have been
recognized around the globe for their
innovative critical thinking
creativity ethical and professional
standards of performance
21st century media skills and leadership
abilities
and the goal of the william hearst
endowment for visiting professionals
is to recognize for our students and
those all across the nation
distinguished individuals like cnn's
chief white house correspondent jim
acosta
in 2018 and documentarians alex civano
and his partner dan rather
in 2019 they along with many incredible
past hearst recipients inspire
generations of college students
with their drive determination and
professionalism
based on ethical and responsible public
service
on all global media platforms we are so
delighted to have you with
us today dr fauci and i know everyone
uh so much enjoyed hearing from you and
looks forward to further
q a i'm happy now to turn things back
over to bob
thank you again and welcome everyone and
a special welcome to dr fauci to san
jose state
and just remember a virtual presence is
close
but it's not all the way so please know
that you have an open invitation
to come visit us when you're out west
when we can all travel
again so bob i turn it back over to you
thank you madam president thank you
indeed madam president
and we will echo that sentiment a little
bit later and doctor please do me the
honor
of just calling me bob i like it when my
students do it
and i would appreciate it if you would
do the same thank you how about you call
me tony
you got it okay and listen i've been
told to make you smile
we should talk about baseball but we got
to get back to the ceremony okay
earlier we saw in our video the chief
operating officer of our city
he has some additional remarks and a
special proclamation for dr fauci
so here again is the mayor of san jose
california
our friend the honorable sam licardo
dr fauci i serve on san jose city
council with 10 of my colleagues
and i can tell you rarely do we agree on
much of anything
but for this commendation all 11 of us
unanimously
agreed to commend you to thank you for
your extraordinary service and
leadership
for our country thank you on behalf of
the more than one million residents of
the city of san jose
thank you mayor and thank you to the
city council for that historic
recognition
you know dr fauci we want to acknowledge
and thank a mutual friend of ours and
his company locally
mr cameron burks vice president of the
global security
of adobe he was part of the planning and
creative
efforts for this virtual ceremony
and his wonderful staff and the people
of adobe
have been our partners for many years
and we hope to be doing more exciting
things with them in the future
so please let me thank not only him but
also
jeff jacobs tony van winkle
and of course superstar editor paul
wright for that wonderful
opening they call a sizzle we'll have to
do more of those
did that make you sizzle doctor
indeed i like that i think we'll try
that again sometime
we should also let you know the zoom
webinar event
is being streamed now live on youtube
and on our san jose state university
website
so that the nation and the world can
witness what you have to say
in a little bit we'll have a few more
questions and interaction with our
campus community and the doctor
but we know that many businesses and
community leaders
here and across the country would also
like to express their individual
thoughts
about dr fauci's